[Music]
friendships must be cultivated
to that end China bestowed an honorary
doctorate on Russia's president last
month at a press conference for the
event Vladimir Putin praised the two
countries relationship Jonah is by any
measure our strategic partner our
biggest trade turnover is with China
Skipton last year trade between the two
countries rose 27% to a hundred and
seven billion dollars Russia sells China
raw materials while China sends back
machinery transport and consumer goods
to increase trade the two were investing
in new transport links like this
cross-border bridge over the Amur River
it's set to open for traffic next year
from window go Eddie Moton school in
Florida build more infrastructure right
now to friendly countries with a long
shared border can't trade normally
because they lack the proper
infrastructure infrastructure both
presidents have promised to remedy that
they've met dozens of times in recent
years and the Kremlin says they have
good personal chemistry as well
president Xi's visit to st. Petersburg
has been in the works for a long time
China and Russia support each other
diplomatically against
anti-globalization protectionism and
unilateralism this fully reflects the
high level and special nature of the two
countries strategic partnership we see
one thing unites China and Russia their
rivalry with the West Russia has been
hit hard by sanctions China's living
with the looming threat of a trade war
with America 30 bilateral agreements are
set to come out of the summit but the
main amias seems to be descent the West
one message we're just fine without you
both Russia and China are permanent
members of the United Nations Security
Council where they often block
resolutions from Western countries
especially relating to Syria and
Venezuela
another key part of the russian-chinese
relationship is increasing military
coordination russian TV news recently
showed joint military exercises 3,000
chinese soldiers joined hundreds of
thousands of Russian troops on maneuvers
last year the low Chinese numbers a sign
that the Russians don't completely trust
them yet we don't intend to become
dependent on China that's why we're
developing relationships with Japan
Korea the ASEAN countries and India
Russia's Asia policy is more than just a
China policy Nicky discovered a sign
that Russian foreign policy is based on
pragmatism and can be easily adjusted
depending on which way the wind blows
GWS Emily Sherwin's following that visit
in Moscow for us I asked her earlier to
tell us about the common interests that
are drawing China and Russia closer
together this is a marriage of
convenience in some ways but there is
also a lot to it a lot of basis to it
Russia and China have a lot a lot in
common when it comes to some of the main
political issues in the international
arena at the moment both support Maduro
in venezuela both are trying to salvage
the Iran nuclear deal both also have a
similar position on the denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula they even have a
joint roadmap that they have been
working out that they've been pushing on
that process they often vote together on
resolutions in the Security Council and
economically as well they've been
developing ties as we just saw in the
piece in recent years Russia is China's
main energy supplier China is Russia's
main trade partner so even though we
have been hearing a lot of rhetoric from
both sides about a deep friendship that
isn't just hot air there is also a basis
to it okay we'll see what what the basis
comes up with today and in terms of
possible trade deals
Emily Sherwin wares in Moscow thanks
much